Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to not only simulate fluids,
but even better, we're going to absorb
them with sponge-like porous materials too.
This paper does not have the usual super high
resolution results that you see with many other
simulation papers. However, I really wanted
to show you what it can do through four lovely
experiments. And, at the end of the episode,
you will see how slowly or quickly it runs!
Experiment number one. Spongy dumbbells. One side
is made of a spongy material, and if it starts
absorbing the water, let’s see if it sinks. Well,
it slowly starts to descend as it gets heavier,
and then, it gets so heavy that eventually, it
sinks the other half too. That is a good start.
Now, experiment number two. Absorption.
Here, the green liquid is hard to absorb,
therefore we expect it to pass through.
While the red liquid is easier to absorb,
and should get stuck in this perforated material.
Let’s see if that is indeed what happens…the green
is coming through, and where is all the red
goo? Well, most of it is getting absorbed here.
But wait, the paper promises to ensure that
mass and momentum still gets transferred
through the interactions properly. So, if
the fluid volumes are simulated correctly,
we expect a lot more green down there than
red. Did we get it? Oh yes, checkmark!
And if you think this was a
great absorption simulation,
wait until you see this. Experiment
number three. Absorption on steroids.
This is a liquid mixture, and these are porous
materials. Each of which will absorb exactly one
component of the liquid and let through
the rest. Let’s see…the first obstacle
absorbs the blue component quickly, the second
retains all the green component, and the red
flows through. And, look at how gracefully
the red fluid fills the last sponge. Lovely.
Onwards to experiment number four. Artistic
control. Since we are building our own little
virtual world, we make all the rules.
So let’s see the first absorption case.
Nothing too crazy here. But, if this is
not in line with our artistic vision,
do not despair, because this is our world, so
we can play with these physical parameters.
For instance, let’s increase the absorption
rate, so that the fluid enters the solid faster.
Or, we can increase the permeability, this is the
ease of passage of the fluid through the material.
Does it transfer quicker into the sponge?
Yes it does! And finally, we can speed up
both how quickly the fluid enters the solid,
how quickly it travels within, and we have
also increased the amount of absorption.
Let’s see if we end up with a smaller remaining
volume. Indeed we do! The beauty of building these
virtual worlds is that we can have these
simulations under our artistic control.
So, how long do we wait for the sponges? Well,
hold on to your papers, because we not only
don’t have to sit down and watch an episode of
Spongebob to get these done, but… get this. The
crazy three-sponge experiment used about quarter
of a million particles for the fluid, and another
quarter-ish million particles for the solids,
and runs at approximately a second per frame.
Yes, it runs interactively, and all
this on a consumer graphics card.
And, yes, so that’s why the resolution of the
simulations is not that high. The authors could
have posted a much higher resolution simulation
and kept the execution time in the minutes per
frame domain, but no. They wanted to show us
what this can do interactively. And in this case,
it is important that you apply the First Law Of
Papers, which says that research is a process.
Do not look at where we are, look at where we will
be two more papers down the line. So, there we go,
I really wanted to show you this paper, because
unfortunately, if we don’t talk about it, almost
no one will see it. This is why Two Minute Papers
exists. And, if you wish to discuss this paper,
make sure to drop by on our Discord server.
The link is available in the video description.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!